good afternoon uh I'm Rob I'm part of
the the hardware team here at coma and
today we're going to talk about how the
device is built
so first of all I think a lot of people
when they think of comma they think of
an AI company like we do a lot of
research a lot of our people are working
on software on on machine learning but
fundamentally comma is also a consumer
electronics company like I mean we
launched a new product this is what uh
what funds or development so this is a
pretty pretty important part of what we
do
um it's also not like we're selling like
simple Electronics like we're selling
electronics that that's somewhat
comparable to like a modern smartphone
like if you think about it we have
we have a high quality screen we have
high quality cameras
um we have a bunch of compute to run the
machine learning models we have
connectivity we have network
connectivity we have LTE we have Wi-Fi
um so yeah it's not a simple product to
build
so we started out a few years ago with
the Eon ion was a pretty simple product
to build I mean we basically uh
we didn't really care about all the the
advanced features we just we bought a
smartphone like all the advanced
features already in a box we slap the
heatsink on it to manage The Thermals uh
put in a 3D printed case
um yeah it's easy to produce uh it's
it's simple it works but it's it's I
mean it's not really a consumer
electronics product right
um
after that uh I think it's about four
years ago now we launched the comma 2.
um this is basically refinement of the
Eon
um product uh so that the most advanced
features like compute sensors are still
inside the metal box so we didn't have
to care about that but we integrated the
electronics that torque to the car into
the case
we refactor the way that we connect to
the car so we can support more cars
um and things gone a little bit more
complex like we started to have to build
more procedures and how to like make
sure that the changes we made were
tested well that the production
processes were good
but then two years ago we launched the
comma 3.
um it was a pretty pretty big step
George always talks about the fact that
comma 3 is the hardest product that
we'll ever have to build and I I do
believe that that's true for a few
reasons
for one
like all the sensors all the the display
the compute the electronics they're all
custom built in-house they're designed
in-house this is something that we'd
never really done before on this scale
so it took a lot of engineering effort a
lot of time improving all the processes
to get this to built uh not only to
design all the individual customized
components but also to integrate them
nicely into one like little box that
looks nice that functions well
that is a form factor that people
actually want to use
so so that's when we did back then then
this year like we've obviously launched
the 3x and George talked extensively
about already which is just a refinement
of the three with with kind of D added
um it's a little ready on the downslope
in terms of complexity
um
so in the future I think we can go even
a step further once we get to larger
numbers of devices sold we can actually
start talking to manufacturers to also
get the modules that we still use to do
connectivity like we still use the
Crackdown module for LTE we still use a
system or module as we refer to the sum
for the compute but we can start
integrating that all into a nice device
and then we handle back to something
that looks more like a smartphone
um
again like if we get to those numbers we
actually uh can customize these uh these
these individual components more so that
the integration will also be easier uh
so I think it'll only get easier from
here
so how do we do it now
so there's actually quite a lot involved
in the whole process so to uh to give
you a sense of that I I've made up this
little nice design of uh like a basic
life cycle of a product within company
with it within coma I don't think it's
due to the similar to all the hard drive
companies but uh it's good to go over it
anyways so we start with a concept so we
basically think about like what the form
factor will look like
um what features we want to have
uh once we've got that nailed down then
we go over to a design step where we
design all the electronics all the
custom parts the mechanical Parts the
case
then we get prototypes built
then we get them tested if they're not
good then go back to step number two uh
usually we iterate like six seven times
before we get a prototype that's ready
for manufacturing
then we actually can put it into
production
and after that we can ship it out to
customers now if it would stop there
that would be nice but we live in the
real world so we'll also get warranty
returns
um
for the 3x
um compared to the three getting the
concept down was a lot easier I mean we
basically have the exact same features
except for the addition of kind of D we
still have the same kind of form factor
a lot of the components stayed in
relatively the same position
so that that part wasn't actually too
hard I've actually found a picture of
the the Whiteboard where we sat down and
wrote down all the all the changes we
wanted to make
and you notice there's
a lot of times we mentioned we mentioned
the word no in the in the feature list
so we removed the pcie lanes because we
don't have the nvme drive anymore
removed the 3.3 Power Wheel so that made
the power actually easier we
we removed uh the the external siren
like we used the the speakers we already
had on the device to do the siren part
um we removed the USB hub because the
panda Now talks over spy to the main
device so it's we removed a lot of stuff
and as Elon always says no part is the
best part so uh that's the general goal
here
um
so once we know what we're building then
we get to the design phase so the
biggest part of design I would say is
the the electronics part so the main
board which starts out as the schematic
on the left
so that's basically where we do all the
like we select all the parts that will
make up the whole design
um we
get them to work all together like we
think of all the edge cases the device
might be in like like when you shut it
down after a while like the power draw
needs to be low like attack on stuff all
gets integrated and thought off when we
do the uh the schematic design
after we're happy that we and we think
that we made all the changes that we
needed to make in the schematic then we
move out move over to the board layout
uh this is actually a picture of the uh
the PCB layout of the comma 3. so you
can see it's it's it's relatively
complex so this is the part where we
place all the components down in a
sensible location
um to make it fit in the form factor we
make we designed the outline of the
board and then we connect all the
components together with uh with the
traces on like six copper layers
to get all the uh the requirements that
we want
um
this is actually a pretty manual step
still because there haven't been very
good software packages out there that
can do this automatically even though
you might think that it's not that hard
like you just connect stuff up together
that needs to be connected up it turns
out there's a lot of
a lot of design requirements that you
need to think about for example all the
high speed traces that carry a lot of
the data from like the cameras to the
compute they need to be impedance
matched they need to be on layers and
further and far enough apart from model
stuff that they don't have crosstalk
with different Lanes you want them to
not have any Electric magnetic
interference
you don't want to admit any RF noise
that you're not allowed to because I
might also degrade TPS or all the
devices in the neighborhood but it's
actually quite complex so this process
like if you start from scratch it
probably takes one and a half two months
to get it down
uh not future reference is obviously
easier because most of the stuff stays
the same
so let's talk a little bit more about
the part selection because in the recent
years that has proved to become more
difficult because of all the shortages
going on
um and not only that but there's also
the thing where uh
there are multiple Parts on the market
with a similar functionality so getting
an optimal design where you can actually
mix and match parts to get the same
features it's pretty important
so how do we internally keep track of
all like the substitutes that work
together of all the inventory that we
have for production
um like what components all the designs
use so we can reuse the same components
well we don't always need to reinvent
the wheel so we actually found this
software called Parts box it's made by a
Polish company there's this one guy who
writes this in the in his spare time
it's actually really cool it's uh it
introduced us to the concept of a
customer part number of CPN a sometimes
also think of it as a comma part number
but
um
so this is basically a part number
that's not like an actual physical part
so that basically just specifies the
requirements that we want for that part
to be so we just say okay we want like
100 kilo one resistor that's one to show
it now in an o4 or two package it's like
a relatively standard component and
there's dozens of Manufacturers that can
can make parts that fits the that fits
these specifications
um so that's the parts you see on the
bottom so that's the parts that we can
actually buy and that we approve
uh to be like a suitable part for the
CPN and we can then order them to make
sure that we have enough for for
production runs the other cool thing
that Parts box has is API access
um
so we also do a lot of CI on our Auto
designs so we can automatically pull
from our inventory numbers and that kind
of stuff and I'll go into depth a little
bit more in the next slides
so this is a commit that I made to the
hardware repo in the last month
finishes rounding of one of the camera
boards uh nothing too interesting but uh
this shows us like all the steps that
are run automatically every time we make
a change
so the first thing we have is it checks
the cpns so it goes over the design that
you just pushed and make sure that every
part in the design actually has a CPN uh
like allocated to it so we don't push
designs where we don't specify like what
the part actually is because that makes
it harder for production like you have
to go back and forth I'm like asking how
much part of the list
so that's that's automatically uh check
that that's uh
all filled out
then the next step is one we added
because one of our earlier prototypes we
made a mistake of putting a capacitor
with a low voltage trading on a
power supply line that was slightly
higher voltage so uh like in in a few
weeks we would see failures with this so
now we actually have a check that goes
over every capacitor and all of our
designs and checks that the the ratings
are actually uh good enough for for the
use case we used for
um the third step is a fiducial's check
for people who don't know what a
fiducial is so that it looks like this
it's a little dot that you put on a PCB
it doesn't have any function in the end
product but it's very useful in
production because that tells the
machine like where the board is actually
located in the machine so it can more
accurately calculate where it needs to
place the components
we tended to make the mistake sometimes
where we would order boards without
placing fiducials on them and then we
would get them into the manufacturing
line and would be a huge hassle to get
prototypes out of them so now you add an
extra check so every time we have a
design and it at least has three
fiducials on the on every board
next one generate gen get files so
that's something that's the file format
that a machines use so we don't have to
manually make that every time we make a
new revision then we also generate board
diff images
so for every commit it tells you where
the copper was at where it was removed
so we can easily like go back and see
which commit actually changed which uh
what what part of the design
because uh I mean the files look like
XML codes so you can't really see what's
going on with the actual design on
GitHub so this is a pretty nice sanity
check to make sure that you actually
commit what you want to commit
um
then we have generating schematic PDFs
because not everybody has the Gap
package installed on their machine so we
just generate PDFs from all the designs
so we can just pull the schematic as a
reference anytime
uh we back up some stuff that's an
automated thing and then recently we've
also added the new parts bot so every
time we now push a revision to a design
it checks and it acts as the particles
Parts box API just talked about and it
checks that all the components we have
on the design are actually in stock like
locally
and if they aren't then we just generate
a message on slacks saying hey please
buy these components when the pcbs
arrived and we actually have all the
components to build them
uh
except for the electrical designs we
also have the mechanical designs
obviously so we do the injection molded
case we do outside all sorts of like
holders for GPS antennas for the dcms
the mounting plates you see on the right
I don't go into too much detail there
because that's that's not usually what I
do that's eager on the back there
um but we yeah regenerate these machine
drawings that we can send off to the the
manufacturers we do some simulation
tests to make sure that all the the
things stay within the lens that we want
them to be
Etc
cool so we're done with the design we
got a bear prototype pcbs
this one's blue you've noticed in
Georgia's talk that the PCB was black
that's one of the ways we make it easy
internally to track like which Pro which
thing is a prototype which one is a
production device
also we tend to change the goal of the
PCB everywhere Vision we do so if you
have like three four revisions on a desk
like you can easily check like okay this
is a ref B this is ref c
um it's been quite helpful
um
so now we have blank pcbs obviously they
need components so what do we do now
well
some people have already talked about
our internal production line that we set
up a few months ago so that's the part
that'll actually put the parts onto the
PCB
the main advantages we've seen from
bringing this production in us because
people ask us like why do you bring it
in-house you can just pay somebody else
to do it and don't have to care about
any of the stuff uh us two things so
first of all it drastically reduces the
cycle time
so with our old manufacturer it would
take like between six and eight weeks to
get a new revision and you'll only get
like two boards and so you hold back and
forth and second of all it's way easier
to fix issues like for example we got a
board made on our line somebody plastic
component like 90 degrees rotated we
just literally walk downstairs change
the value in the machine work back up
and an hour later you have a new
revision on your desk with the required
fixes
um with the old company it would be an
email chain of three days and then we
might get it right
okay first machine so the board goes
into the machine
and that machine applies the solar paste
so to stick components down to your
board you need some solid base that
melts in the oven to create the solder
bonds
um most Mass manufacturing uh
manufactures they use a stencil based
machine so you get these
stainless steel based stencils with
holes card on them you have a big
squeegee that just squeegees down your
solid paste
um it's very nice it's very fast so it
only takes like a second or two to paste
the PCB the problem is it's very hard to
iterate with like if you make a new
change you have to make a new stencil
you have to reload the stencil in the
PCB every time you change the designs
out so that adds a bunch of time with uh
switching designs and making your
revisions this one just as a as a tube
with some solid paste in it and it just
dispenses tiny little dots on the bats
and uh it's just CNC controlled so you
can just put any design in it and it
works
as also the cycle time is not very
important in this step
because uh the whole production line is
pipelined so even as long as this takes
less time than it takes to populate the
board this won't hold down the total
production rate that we can achieve so
there's actually not that many downsides
to doing it this way
next machine pick and place machine so
the pick and place machine is loaded up
with a bunch of reels of components and
it does exactly what the name suggests
it does it has nozzles Picks Them Up
from reels places and then on the board
our machine also has an extra cool
feature that I really like it does
electrical testing as well of every
component a very passive component so
for example if it picks up 100K resistor
usually these parts have tolerances
because we live in the real world
it'll place them down on the dashboard
it'll measure the exact value log into a
database somewhere like related to the
serial number of a board that's in there
so we can in the future always look back
and see exactly which value resistor was
placed in there
um it's pretty cool
next up in the line the oven
pretty States pretty straightforward so
you just put the board in moves over the
conveyor it gets hot it's all the melts
that's pretty much it you'd think but
then there's a lot of tweaking in the
oven so the oven has about eight zones
they can all be set at a different
temperature
and then the conveyor belt speed can
also be modified and it's it's a
balancing act between like multiple uh
parameters that you need to tune
for example in the first five zones on
this uh this slide you'll see that the
temperature slowly moves up
and that's to give the flux contents
that that's inside the solar base some
time to uh to clean up the oxidation of
the pads which makes it way more likely
to get good solar Bond then it moves
into zone six and seven where the
temperature rises up quickly to above
the melting point of the solar balls
that are in the solid paste the bomb
gets formed and then there's a
controlled cool down in the next two or
three zones to make sure that that
everything settles down nicely
a lot of the components that we use
actually have limitations on for example
the uh the the the temperature rate the
temperature gradient that they that they
can can sustain so for example the image
sensors I think you have to heat up less
than three celsius a second I cool down
less than six Celsius a second and
there's also something that you have to
keep in mind when tweaking all these uh
solo zones
next up in the line we technically have
a functioning board if everything went
well the problem is we don't know if
everything went well like what if
somebody like bumped the PCB some
components moved or we loaded the wrong
part into the machine or failed to pick
up a part and didn't notice well that's
why we have automated Optical inspection
so it's that machine it's basically a
fancy camera with a bunch of lights that
can move
um just flies over the board and checks
out every component and makes sure that
it matches a reference picture from a
known good board so this is especially
useful in production where if you're
running like thousands of boards you
know that every board actually has all
the components and it doesn't have any
any failures that would be easy to
detect this this way
uh
doesn't know the benefit the family
machines announce is that we can do a
lot of vertical integration with them so
we talked about parts parts box having
an API all the machines also have an API
so uh this is some software we wrote
in-house to um
program the machines because if you're a
contract manufacturer you usually get
like an Excel sheet of all like the
parts and the mounts positions that the
parts need to be placed at then somebody
has to like sit there manually enter
like the hundreds of components that are
on the design
um select from which CPN like which npn
was actually in stock which one's on
machine which is which one is not well I
mean we've built a software it requires
Parts box so to check which components
we actually have an inventory it checks
which parts are actually already loaded
on the machine so if you have multiple
accepted mpns for a CPN it can like
prioritize the ones that are already
loaded and then we just throw in like
the cat file that we have automatically
generates all of this it's literally a
five minute process and we have
programmed all the machines
so we have built prototype devices does
everything work well
to verify that everything works you need
test plans
so we have very extensive unit tests for
every single feature that we want out of
the device
so this functionally test that
everything works that's on the board
like you expected it to work based on
the design it also checks for extreme
environments so we do a lot of tests in
like thermal Chambers to make sure that
it goes up to the that everything still
works at the temperature that it might
reach up in the car it goes down to a
certain temperature
it also there's some some minor stress
testing where we like
um inject voltage transients into
certain lines to make sure that the
protection circuits we've built in work
we make sure that if you plug in a wrong
cable into the wrong hole nothing breaks
like all that stuff is is validated
before we move on
then if we think that's all good then we
have some more compliance tests so those
are actually mandatory if you want to
start consuming Electronics you have to
bring it to like a certified test lab
and then make sure that a you're not
intentionally radiating any RF noise on
frequencies that you're not allowed to
radiate on like
and then there's the second part of the
tests which makes sure that the modules
you've integrated that actually you want
to transmit don't transmit at a power
level that's too high or that they don't
create any modular
effects
and then there's a third step we do
field testing so we first put them in
all our cars so we have 12 cars and a
fleet it covers most of the platforms we
support but then there's some some other
ones that Community only has so that's
why we do the uh the Apple program so we
have some few members here I think you
guys here
yes
um
and uh that's actually proven to be very
successful so in this round of Apple
testing for the 3x we've actually found
two bucks
um one of the bugs was a software bug
with the um the new panda that's
integrated on the board it was used in
slightly different ways than the red
band that was in the past so we we fixed
some some bug related to kind of D but
there's also a hardware back that was
discovered that we didn't discover with
all the test plans we've previously done
which was with uh Jason's third-party uh
long cables uh VW uses all this weird
stuff it occurs I don't know uh so yeah
we always use the the official cables
because they're laying around in the
office so I
it's it's good to get some coverage from
the community as well
so once that's done
and we're happy with it it moves on to
uh production so we now buy all the
parts in bulk we so that's like the
cheapest components make sure we have
everything in stock and then we get the
pcbs built in in Black like mentioned
before we apply the QR code stakex
actually data Matrix not a QR code but
same thing so this adds a unique serial
number to each board such that we can
later on if we if it comes back to the
heart of theory we can double check that
like the oven will set at the right
temperature when it was run that all the
electric components measured their uh
their respective values uh we can check
the aoi images like to see if that
missed anything that that it shouldn't
have uh so that's a pretty nice addition
then when it I mean it runs through the
whole circus book line the exact same as
the
prototypes so then we have assembled
boards and then we move on to all our
provisioning steps
so first of all we have initial
provisioning so this is a step we've
added for the 3x
um
and it basically takes the bare boards
that came straight off the line we just
put on the lens holders lenses in them
uh puts them in this nice jig and it
does a bunch of blackberry preliminary
tests so it checks that all the voltage
rails are in intolerance it checks that
we can talk to most of the components it
does like an initial flashing round of
the internal panda
um and then it has the the focusing step
so it's very important that the lenses
that we place on the devices are like
perfectly in Focus because it's fixed
Focus so we can change it in the future
and would be a hardware return if
they're not uh so we made this this UI
thingy where you just turn the lenses
you try to get the green light to go as
high as possible and then we know that
the devices are in focus
now obviously on the bare boards we
haven't placed the Som or the compute
module on the board yet so we needed to
design something else for that so we
designed what we call a fake zomb which
is basically a separately
like a a separate module in the same
form factor as a song but that can be
powered externally so we can just keep
it alive when switching between boards
just make sure that we don't have to
like reboot Linux every time before we
run tests so that increase the cycle
times plus it has like the voltage
testing stuff built in and all that nice
stuff
then the next step is we built them out
into full devices so the heatsinks got
placed on uh d-cam gets placed on the
GPS gets placed on that they get put
into the cases the screen gets placed on
that's quite a lot of steps in the case
we also add an NFC tag and you'll see
where that's useful for Lake
after they've been built into the final
form they move on to what we call final
provisioning this is a
wooden rack we have set up in our
production environment with some some
mounts
so they they get connected up there and
then we run through like a full Suite of
Hardware tests so we make sure that
every piece of Hardware that's inside
that's that's uh on the device like the
Imus the GPS the Wi-Fi the screen all
that stuff that's all tested so we make
sure that that
we know that everything works before we
ship it out to customers
this is also a place where like from
time to time new tests get added because
we've seen failures from the field for
example a few weeks ago we had some
returns of display panels where like the
touch wouldn't work in like a certain
area of the screen so we just added a
test where you just like wipe the whole
screen so we make sure that the whole
screen works and so we that's that's
like the procedure we follow to reduce
failures more and more
as time goes on
after that we move on to the stress test
so that's another bigger wooden rack
this is only a small portion of it
um
where the devices are placed on for 24
hour
cycle test
so on this test we put them on their
High synthetic loads so we just max out
the CPU usage Max our GPU usage DSP
usage we run the cameras at full speed
run the fans at full speed
um just to make sure that the devices
actually stay working for like a
reasonable amount of time because
um
sometimes like soft works but then like
it heats up and then stops working so
that's the kind of feelings we try to
catch here this is also the place where
we do some longer running tests like we
make sure that the GPS signal doesn't
drop for 24 hours
we make sure that if we toggle fan on
and off once in a while that it starts
back up
we make sure that the camera doesn't
drop any frames during the whole 24
hours
and those those things have really
reduced the amount of failures that we
see uh in the field
after they've gone through that they're
ready to ship so they go move over to
fulfillment where we automatically test
using the NFC tag because we know where
the device has been so we put the device
on there
uh on our reader let me know if the
device passed all our tests
because then he always used to be the
case in the old comma two days in the
old office like device would get
misplaced or like not all the tests
would have been run and then we would
get shipped out anyways so now we
explicitly uh confirmed this uh for the
comma three so you have to make sure
that we're the correct type like if you
buy one terabyte one you get a 32 gig
one people will complain the other way
around not so much but still not still
not great
um
domestic orders we include a SIM card
for the comma Prime trials International
AutoZone so that's also something that's
verified
this also tells you which harness the
customer bought so we place the Right
One In The Box it also checks that we
have the latest software uh flashed onto
the device because if it's been sitting
in storage for a while like if we uh we
have some some access inventory it might
be on an old open battle version and the
first clone would take a lot longer
so this is something uh something we try
to prevent
and then there's the final cosmetic
inspection before they get the box gets
shut there's also an aoi it's not
automated Optical inspection we call it
Ada Optical inspection because she's the
one that has the Fulfillment
um
so yeah
and then the heart of failures
um
we used to get emails all the time that
said oh my device doesn't work anymore
and I mean there's not much you can do
about that except for ask the customer
to return the device and then in most
cases it turned out that the device was
fine but it was installed wrong or the
software didn't support that car yet or
there was some other softenberg that we
didn't know about yet
um
so we recently changed that process and
made sure that when there's Hardware
complaints people actually provide us
with a route where the issue occurs so
that an engineer first looks into the
into the the
alleged failures and if that's actually
someone normally going uh going on then
we get it sent back otherwise we tell
the customers like what's going wrong
and we don't have to do any unnecessary
shipments
this is actually reduced or inbound for
for uh
influx like the inbound for the failures
by close to an order of magnitude so
that's been quite good for us
but then the devices that do come back
we have to take him quite seriously
because usually there's something we can
do about it
um
for example one of the earlier failures
of the gamma 3 had to do with the soms
failing
and it turns out that we used to use a
thermal pad on top of the main CPU
and with manufacturing tolerances and
thermal cycling that would put too much
pressure inside on top of the dye which
caused some solar failures
so then we change the procedure to go
with a putty based thermal compound
which reduced the the total pressure on
top of the chip by
2X and that practically resolved the
issue overnight
another thing we can do is add
additional testing like for example the
touch issue I talked about before like
we just add a lot of tests to make sure
these don't these devices don't get
shipped out in the first place
or we actually can also improve the
design like if it's a an actual design
bug we had one a while back with red
pandas for example where we didn't
account for people plugging in a USB
cable with 12 volts on it on a port that
one's supposed to get 12 volts and then
would blow out the camera and Civics so
that's just fixed we made a new revision
it doesn't happen anymore
and that really translates in the
failure rate so uh Georgia already
alluded to this but the all-time failure
rate of the gamma 3 has been at 9.2
percent now
um
it's an interesting number but it's
actually more interesting to look at
what's failure it's been over the last
year
so we load it to 3.9 already
just by improving all these processes
um
to put that into a little bit of expect
perspective George already did some of
this but uh iPhone 6 is 22 recent
iPhones three four percent
um Xboxes 22 percent
PlayStation 3s was it ten percent
we're actually close to a Wii that's
pretty good Hardware apparently uh but
we intend to do a lot better with the 3x
I I think with some uh some more
improvements and with a more reliable
design I think we can get that probably
get it down to like one to one or two
percent
so that's that's pretty pretty good
so uh
I mean George gets to announce Hardware
products when we also get to announce
something
um
that's not on there
you guys know harness boxes
a lot smaller now we don't I mean
they're in the final stages of testing
so they'll come out in a few months
probably uh injection molded case it
would be a lot easier to fit on the uh
the covers and more scars
then another one that we're coming out
with soon uh New Panda jungle so it's a
can of the variant it adds a Z card
support it adds per Channel if users
per Channel as bu line control all that
stuff that uh has been very nice for
developers internal and hopefully
external as well
so okay I've been talking for says 35
minutes now I'm only I only have 45
minutes so
there's still a lot more that we haven't
talked about
this part shortages let's talk about
screwdrivers this packaging this
injection moldings boom optimization
cable testing suppliers
harness production mounting plates
through hole soldering display
calibration laser deep analyzation
pandas comma bodies you name it the
hardware team has a lot to do
so uh if you're interested
reach out to us we can definitely use an
extra hand
or if you have more questions then feel
free to uh
ask him now
[Applause]
all right thank you robba we got a
question up here in the front
thank you
um you talked about compliance testing
are you planning to do only FCC or are
you looking also
European one like easy and others
um we've done the FCC one now the
European one is very similar
so we'll uh we'll probably be complying
with that as well
great
so the um
the harness connector is changing
because you've got a smaller box yes how
do you make that what's that equation
like for making the trade-off is it time
to
uh yes so the the I think the old one
was a 24 pin if I'm not mistaken the new
one is a little bit smaller
um I mean we had to because otherwise
the case wouldn't be smaller uh the new
connectors will just come with the new
harnesses so we'll have to move over the
production a little bit but functional
functionally that's not that big of a
difference it doesn't have a mechanical
relay anymore by the way so we'll get
rid of the little click you hear when
open pilot starts but it'll be a lot
more reliable hopefully so yeah that'll
be good
we got any other questions
oh in the back I'm coming
hi um so I was impressed by your
automated testing on on commits to the
repo uh how is it that you do the diff
between the old board and the new boards
um oh it's it's not super efficient
computationally but we've gotten uh
Eagle the cat package we used to run
inside of the CI Docker container so we
basically just spin up Eagle open the
files generate uh girl books then
generates pngs from the gerberus and
then we just do an image diff on the two
images
sweet and we're also looking for
Hardware Engineers are there any uh
like networking events that you know of
in San Diego where we can all uh I don't
really know of that many actually no
the truth is that Rob is based in
Belgium that's also true
so he definitely does not know about uh
the happenings in San Diego oh we got a
question back here
I'm wondering um do you have any
interesting stories about weird issues
that took a long time to track down and
end up having an interesting cause
um
we have so many good bug stories we have
a lot of them there's much bugs Nabil on
both the comet two and the comma 3s
we've we've had a lot of GPS troubles
um this apparently like uh the the the
845s the main chips they leak quite a
bit of RF across the whole Spectrum so
you have to isolate them very well to
not affect GPS uh the Commodus we had an
issue where the
GPS antenna has this internal LNA
amplifier
so it amplifies the signal but then we
had an issue where it leaked out after
the amplifier into the heatsink and I
got coupled back into the antenna so now
we would get like a feedback loop that
one took a long time to track down
[Music]
um
well all the ones that we got how about
last week when a vendor sent a wrong
component and mislabeled it oh yeah
that's another great one so last week we
were placing uh inductors on the boards
on the three axes actually uh don't
worry we fixed it but uh
um
so we got we ordered uh one micro Henry
inductors from a reputable Supply they
came to us we loaded them into the
machine and then uh Eagle on a hardware
guy he like he needed one so he just
took one off the line and when taking it
off we looked at the reel it was like
hey there's two labels on here one of
them says one Micah Henry one of them
says 2.2
it turns out uh it was the wrong part
so uh yeah
got to be careful even with official
distributors
so we heard George talk about custom
Asics where does this stand on the
hardware roadmap have you guys thought
about it at all
uh I think George has some architectural
plans but I don't think that's uh that's
that's going to be concrete anytime soon
yeah
yeah quite far off from the budgets
needed to uh to to spin out H6
so people frequently Express concern
over the thermal resiliency of the
devices can you speak about the steps
that you take during production for both
the C3 and now the the 3x to mitigate
that uh yes so I mean the basic process
we follow is we just test them at
extreme temperatures and then we make
sure that the parts don't fill at those
temperatures we just cycle lots of times
and then we fix the issues that uh that
arise
the second part of the thermal issues is
also not necessarily for failures but
also for uh like user experience for
example when it's like sitting on your
windshield when the sun's blasting on it
uh the device can get quite hot they
want to cool down as fast as possible so
you actually want to reduce like the
total thermal Mass on the device uh so
yeah there's quite a lot of
consideration going on in the in that
regard
but so far with like all the improved
soldering processes we don't see that
many thermal cycling failures anymore so
hey um
you know occurring Hardware or there is
like automation inside all that
um well when we get failures back we
often just run them through the
provisioning tests again and that
usually gives us uh like that narrows
down the component that actually failed
and then we disassemble the devices if
you look at another microscopes and then
Trace down what the actual issue might
be
so it's it's mostly a manual process but
we use some of the the production tests
to guide it
all right we've got time for a few more
questions
um yeah I had a question about the GPS
module in the qutel uh how does that
compare to I think you were using a Neo
m8p yes what do you think like is it
worse better
um I think performance wise it's pretty
similar I think we got on the crackdel
into a mode where it sends us the actual
raw measurements uh and and turn off all
the processing that it does inside
um but the I mean the correct module
uses Qualcomm chips inside and I mean
phones have pretty good GPS these days
so the hardware level is quite good so
we got about comparable performance with
uh with the EU blocks modules as we do
with the uh
the correct else now
Robo what's your favorite part of the 3x
process the favorite part yeah which one
probably the most Joy
oh that's a difficult one
um
I really like the new image sensors like
a nicer easier throughout we have better
specs
cool components
we got any additional questions
all right
how do you manage being in Belgium while
they're here
you're the hardware guy well you get
used to it it's uh I used to be in San
Diego for a year so I know the team very
well as well
um and then we communicate over slack so
I make sure when the US is awake that I
got all my questions answered and I can
continue working the next day sometimes
it's nice as well like you're just
you're sitting by yourself quiet and you
just plow through it
[Laughter]
about 1 to quarter yeah every Wednesday
Rob and I have a lunch meeting yeah yeah
and every Monday we do a team meeting
commas with super low on meetings yeah
uh we have an all hands and then a team
meeting every week and that's about it
yep
all right thank you so much rubber
[Applause]